un cohete es lanzado desde una
plataforma su altura en metros x
segundos después de lanzamiento está
modelada por hdx igual a menos 4 que
multiplicamos a x + 2 que multiplica a x
menos 18 y la primera pregunta nos dice
cuál es la altura del cohete en el
momento del lanzamiento pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo
bueno cuanto vale x en el momento del
lanzamiento si x es el número de
segundos después del lanzamiento en el
momento del lanzamiento x vale 0 así que
déjame ponerlo x es igual a 0 en el
momento del lanzamiento
entonces la altura del cohete el momento
del lanzamiento es h de cero y bueno 70
es igual a y vamos a sustituir a x por
cero
entonces h de cero va a ser igual a
menos cuatro este primer menos cuatro
que tengo aquí que multiplica a cero más
200 más dos es 2 que va a multiplicar a
0 menos 18 lo cual es menos 18 y veamos
cuánto es esto
esto es lo mismo que menos 4 por 2 s
menos 8 que multiplica a menos 18 y
bueno esto es lo mismo que bueno lo
puedo escribir como menos 8 que
multiplica a menos 9 que a su vez
multiplica a 2 menos 9 por 2 es menos 18
y menos 8 por menos 9 esos 72 positivo
por 2 bueno esto es lo mismo que 144 así
que ya puedo escribirlo la altura del
cohete en el momento de lanzamiento es
de 144 metros segunda pregunta en
cuántos segundos después del lanzamiento
el cohete toca el suelo pausa el vídeo e
intenta lo que significa que el cohete
toque el suelo significa que la altura
debe de ser igual a cero por lo tanto
quiere saber en cuántos segundos después
del lanzamiento la altura es igual a
cero
esencialmente tengo que 0 es igual a
menos 4 que multiplican a x + 2 ok esto
a su vez multiplica a x menos 18
ok y en este caso tenemos el producto de
tres cosas distintas
igual a cero entonces al menos uno de
estos productos tiene que ser igual a
cero menos cuatro nunca es igual a cero
por lo tanto podemos decir que primero x
+ 2 es igual a cero déjame ponerlo por
aquí x + 2 es igual a 0 y si restamos 2
de ambos lados voy a llegar a que x es
igual a menos 2 esto en el primer caso
pero recuerda x es el número de segundos
después del lanzamiento
entonces x igual a menos 2 ocurre antes
del lanzamiento por lo tanto podemos
descartar este valor de x no es lo que
buscamos o bueno el segundo caso es que
x menos 18
déjame ponerle climb x menos 18 es igual
a cero
en cuyo caso si sumamos 18 de ambos
lados voy a llegar a que x es igual a 18
y es justo lo que nos preguntan en
cuántos segundos después del lanzamiento
el cohete toca el suelo
bueno tocará el suelo en x igual a 18
segundos perfecto tercera pregunta en
cuántos segundos después del lanzamiento
el cohete llega a su altura máxima pausa
el vídeo e intenta encontrar esta
tercera respuesta bueno la clave aquí es
recordar que si tienes una curva en
particular en este caso una parábola que
se vea más o menos así bueno está para
hablar va a alcanzar una altura máxima
justo aquí para este valor de x es decir
entre sus dos ceros o entre sus dos
intersecciones con el eje x para nuestra
suerte sabemos cuáles son nuestras
intersecciones con el eje x
este punto de aquí toman el valor de x
igual a 18 que fue justo lo que
encontramos acá y por otra parte también
sabemos que hdx es igual a cero cuando x
es igual a menos 2 es decir justo en
este valor de aquí y entonces la
respuesta de esta pregunta es la x que
están a la mitad del camino es decir
entre x igual a menos 2 y x igual a 18
entonces me quedaría menos 2 más 18
entre 2 es decir el promedio y esto es
lo mismo que 16 entre 2 lo cual es igual
a 8 entonces en x igual a 8 segundos
nuestro cohete me alcanza la máxima
altura última pregunta cuál es la altura
máxima que alcanza el cohete una vez más
pausa el vídeo e intenta responder esta
última pregunta
bueno ya sabemos por la respuesta
anterior que el cohete alcanza la mayor
altura en x igual a 8 segundos 8
segundos después del lanzamiento por lo
tanto para obtener la altura máxima lo
que necesitamos es evaluar nuestra
función en 8 es decir encontrar h de 8
recuerda esto es lo que nos dice nuestra
función nos dice cuál es la altura en
metros x segundos después del
lanzamiento
entonces me va a quedar bueno me queda
menos 4 que multiplica a 828 más 2 que a
su vez multiplica a 8 menos 18
ok y cuánto es esto
esto es igual a menos 482 es 10 entonces
menos 4 que multiplica a 10 y 8 menos 18
es lo mismo que menos 10 entonces esto
que multiplica a menos 10 y tengo menos
4 por 10 es menos 40 por menos 10 es 400
positivo 400 metros esa es mi altura
máxima y hemos terminado así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo